[Music]
we're just over a week away from
thanksgiving can you believe it and many
families are looking for a
safe way to celebrate as coronavirus
cases soar the cdc
recommends only celebrating with people
in your household
but if you are joining others the cdc
says you should wear a mask
when you're not eating stay six feet
apart and if you're inside
keep the windows open psychologist and
cbs news contributor lisa demour joins
us with how to handle
difficult decisions and conversations
around the holidays lisa good morning
thanks for being with us
what is what is your advice to people
about it good to see you yeah great to
see you too
i wish you could be here many people are
still deciding how to
to deal with the holiday as close as it
is what's your advice
you know this is such a tough one and
it's hard because there's really no good
decision you know either people have to
deal with disappointing themselves or
their families or they have to assume
some really frightening risks
so the first thing i think to do is to
recognize that there's no
perfect way to go about this and then to
make the choice that actually
one can really live with and the
challenge we're up against right now
is that we have been in this pandemic so
long and it feels tedious and familiar
and yet we have to reconcile that with
the fact that it is as dangerous as it
has
ever been and i think we really need to
let those record rates drive decision
making
right once you make a decision about
what you're going to do you have to have
the conversation with the family
what's the best way to do that
you know i think different families
handle this in different ways you know
some families do well by getting this
information in doses
right so it might be worth calling and
saying i'm having questions about coming
and then following up later and saying
i've decided i can't come
other families do well getting hard news
all at once and so that may be the way
to go
what we want to bear in mind is that
when it comes to delivering bad news
what people like least is surprises so
if you've decided that you're not going
to go and you know that's going to be
hard for someone to hear
you should probably tell them as soon as
you've made that decision yourself
what about kids lisa this has been such
a hard year for them a lot of them
obviously looking forward to holidays
and traditions
that they've had for years what do you
how do you approach kids
about this
you know with kids i think we start with
safety they understand that you know we
say we have to make the decision that is
safe
and then we are clear and calm and
direct
about telling them what's happening and
i think if we
cannot do the holidays as we normally do
we make room for them to be sad
and disappointed we don't have to talk
them out of it they have a right to
those feelings
after that i think we can work with them
about getting creative and kids are
great at this
so we could say maybe look we're not
going to do our regular thanksgiving but
maybe we do you know
a movie marathon and four kinds of
popcorn if they're still struggling
and they might be what we can say is
that there are times when we make
personal sacrifices
on behalf of a greater good and that's
what we're doing here
and we can actually help them feel proud
about their part in that
yeah that they're playing a role you
know joe biden has mentioned this about
the empty chair at the table it's always
tough that first holiday
after you've lost someone what's your
advice to families that are going
through that that's a lot of families
this year
that is a lot of families there's a lot
of people in that boat so the first
thing i would say is we should be
mindful of who those people are in our
communities we should be reaching out to
them
if there's a safe way to connect in
person consider that otherwise just
reach out digitally
i would also say that people who are
suffering should not hesitate to reach
out there is help available
but the piece that we want to remember
and the story about that chair really
gets at that
is that holidays are about times of
reflection
and gratitude and thinking about and
connecting with the people we love
and just because we can't do that in the
regular way doesn't mean that we can't
do it
this year lisa i want to pick up on
connecting with people you love because
if those people come over and your
household tries to follow the cdc
guidelines windows open six feet apart
you wear a mask when you're not eating
there are gonna be families split over
the wisdom
of those recommendations maybe arguing
about it if you're the host
how do you get in the middle say your
daughter arguing with your uncle
over whether to wear a mask
you know i think we say look i love you
both we all want to get together and
enjoy each other and have a good time
and in order for that to be possible
people have to be comfortable
and i know we don't want to do anything
that makes someone here uncomfortable so
let's just go ahead and follow the cdc
guidelines
that way we can all be at ease all right
going to be an interesting thanksgiving
blame it on the cdc yeah lisa demour
thank you so much for being with us
neutral third party
yeah okay